[Music]
under the shadow of the mighty world
tree egg drasil three factions battled
for supremacy in a strange and hostile
new land this is the world of rend an
innovative team-based survival game set
in the apocalyptic aftermath of Ragnarok
rend is the first game from frost cube
studios an indie developer comprised of
talents who can list World of Warcraft
overwatch League of Legends and wildstar
on their collective resume their mission
is to create a survival game that not
only inspires cooperation and creativity
but is also quite simply fun to play
here are five ways that Rend
distinguishes itself from the survival
pack number one there's no I in survival
well apart from the first one obviously
when you join a server you must first
choose to align yourself with one of
three rival factions Conclave order or
revenant each faction supports a maximum
of twenty players
meaning you could roam the diverse
biomes of a ravaged Midgard in the
company of 59 other players everybody's
in the same boat to begin with you have
no clothes no supplies and no shelter
and in a game where hunger thirst and
even temperature are a constant threat
to your well-being it's imperative that
you immediately scavenge enough raw
materials to dress armed and feed
yourself once you're self-sufficient you
can start to work towards the greater
good each faction has a base which is
protected by a shield while most of the
time anyway more on that later
everyone's efforts be that gathering
crafting hunting fighting or gaining
insight into the environments feed into
the entire tribes resources and
knowledge allowing you to grow your base
and your collective skill set rend is
not a game for the selfish yes you'll
always need to keep one eye on your
various metres to ensure you don't drop
dead from starvation exposure or a
massive wolf bite but your real focus
should be on making like a doomsday
prepper and stockpiling for the war
ahead because number two war is coming
rend is at once a pvp and PVE experience
in the process of shattering Midgard
Ragnarok has also angered a
lot of the local wildlife and so the
further you stray from the safety of
your bass the more likely it is you'll
run into hostile beasts in search of
fast food as such arming yourself is
critical to avoiding an embarrassing
walk of shame back to your lost gear
then of course there's the matter of up
to 40 other player-controlled warriors
wandering the land doing their utmost to
ensure their faction superiority run
into a rival and there's really only one
option fight
despite the ancient mythological setting
wrens combat is range focused offering
an array of craftable bows that evoke
classic firearm archetypes your standard
short bow is wrens equivalent of a rifle
a single shot weapon that works best at
range crossbows our first style assault
rifles repeaters are SMGs and so on
knowing your way around a weapon is
vital not just for these accidental
encounters but for a couple of
game-changing features that could turn
the tide in favor of your faction first
up there's control points these ancient
relics are dotted around various
strategic points on the map and once
captured will grant your faction all
manner of tactical bonuses including xp
loot and artifacts items artifacts are
one-of-a-kind weapons and equipment that
endow you with superhuman abilities as
you can imagine this makes control
points highly desirable and hence are
likely to be a reason for rival factions
to group up and wrestle for Dominion but
these skirmishes are far from the war I
alluded to they're merely a prelude to
the reckoning remember how I said that
faction bases are protected by a shield
most of the time yep well the reckoning
accounts for the rest of that time twice
a week on the official servers the
shield's on olfaction bases come down
and a PvE war commences from the spirit
realm emerges hordes of the lost
dishonored warriors returned as mindless
monsters all in pursuit of your
destruction they'll march in
increasingly challenging waves doing
their damnedest to bring down your
factions harder and score and
potentially the entire faction with it
the lost are tougher than the beasts
you'll typically encounter so taking
them down requires preparation and
collaboration preparation comes in the
form of developing and constructing
automated turrets and reinforced walls
while collaboration means combining
offense with your faction mates to where
the loss down and earned plenty of XP
and faction score in the process should
you survive this assault there's
absolutely no room to breathe
all faction based shields will remain
inoperative and the PvE war makes way
for a PvP war leaving you with a big
decision to make do you hang back and
protect your devastated base from
further attack or do you mount a raid on
your rivals which brings me to point
three you can actually win and lose and
like other survival games Rend actually
has a win state one aspect I've
deliberately failed to mention so far is
that all this base building and inter
faction rivalry has a point
boiled down to its core rend is a race a
three-way contest to be the first to
gather enough spirits to earn the right
to ascend to Valhalla any spirits
gathered during your travels are
automatically deposited in the divinity
stone within your base as the divinity
stone is actually connected to incra
cells roots your progress can be tracked
as a glowing bar edged on to the trunk
of the world tree however the amounts of
spirits held can go up and down control
points play a huge part in keeping those
spirits coming as they not only generate
them but also deposit them directly to
your stone then of course there's the
aforementioned option to storm into a
rivals base and ruin all of their hard
work obviously the same can happen to
you and between a vicious assault by the
lost and human vultures come reckoning
day you could be facing losses that will
set your efforts back by days and that's
actual days not in-game ones but if
after potentially months of struggle
your faction reigns victorious you'll be
chosen to join the surviving gods in
Valhalla on a more practical level
you'll also be granted a greater number
of Ascension points which can be
exchanged for perks that persist across
all servers and future game cycles
number four it's a fascinating hybrid of
genres in order to address what some
perceives to be the less desirable
aspects of the survival genre rend
cherry-picks elements from mmo's MOBAs
and sandbox games the introduction of a
win-loss state is obviously a big one
but this influence is also evident
from the sheer breadth and depth of
crafting and character customization
options crafting is the first aspect
you'll encounter as it's essential for
gearing yourself up with the
fundamentals beyond rudimentary tools
basic clothing and simple weaponry
you'll discover an extensive array of
crafting categories most of which
contain items unavailable to you from
the get-go this is yet another example
of how Rend encourages collaboration in
order to grow your crafting options
you'll have to build and upgrade
crafting stations in your base and in
order to do that everyone needs to
donate the sparks of genius earned from
performing general actions to the bases
research obelisks in fact everything you
do in rend rewards you in some way for
every action you're able to perform
there's an Associated skill 15 in total
spread across three broad categories
adventuring crafting and combat these
can all be individually leveled up to a
maximum of 50 and award you a choice of
two perks each time he hits a key
milestone adding even greater
flexibility to your character
development is the archetype system your
character can permanently adopt two of
four available archetypes assassin
warlord Pathfinder and Shaymin and each
of those has its own talent tree full of
useful passive and active talents your
learn points to boost these talents as
your character levels up giving you
plenty of opportunity to tailor a
character that suits your style of play
number five you can ride a giant wolf or
as they're known in Rend prowl fangs
which is a much cooler name anyway most
of the creatures roaming wrens biomes
aren't only there to fill your inventory
with nourishing meats and useful pelts
for crafting they're also there to offer
you a sweet ride and back you up in
combat transforming a creature from a
snarling man-eating beast into your
snarling man-eating beasts isn't simple
sadly no you're gonna have to kill them
first seems impractical but in a game
where you can traverse between the realm
of the living and the spirit realm it's
quite possible to bring a freshly slain
creature back from the dead and under
your thrall once you've crafted the
means of entering the spirit realm
you'll have to do some serious
preparation the spirit realm itself
isn't a place for the corporeal so your
vitals will drain at an increasing rate
the longer you hang about then you've
got the matter of the lost roaming
around and as we've already established
they're not ones for small talk finally
you've got to do your research when it
comes to taming the Beast of your
choosing do they respond to a certain
type of food magic auras maybe perhaps
they need to be shot with spirit arrows
provided you figure out the best
approach and emerge relatively unscathed
congratulations you're the proud owner
of a freshly resurrected pet depending
on which of rennes diverse fauna you've
tamed you'll gain a welcome boost in a
number of departments some are born
fighters or great for hauling heavy
resources while others might make
harvesting a breeze or provide vital
muscle when laying siege to our control
points or base you can't ride on all of
them sadly but you can definitely ride a
giant wolf if you fancy yourself worthy
enough to survive against the odds
vanquish your enemies and earn your
rightful place among the gods rend is
exclusively available in early access on
Steam